am 30 september 2015 übergab
bundesminister magister gerald klug
sechs geschützte mehrzweckfahrzeuge
iveco usa an das kommando militärstreife
und militärpolizei
soldatinnen und soldaten des kommandos
militärstreife und militärpolizei ich
wünsche ihnen eine verantwortungsvolle
aufgabe in allen künftigen einsätzen
alles gute und viel glück mit diesen
neuen zukunftsweisenden fahrzeugen alles
gute und viel soldatenglück diese
fahrzeuge bieten den soldaten besonderen
schutz gegen beschuss minen sprengfallen
und granatsplitter sie verfügen über
blaulicht und folgetonhorn und eine aus
dem inneren des fahrzeuges
fernbedienbare waffenstationen
die soldaten werden taktisch bewusst auf
der dem objekt abgewandten seite des als
mobile deckung verwendeten fahrzeuges
zum ort des einsatzes gebracht
minister würden zeugen den betrieben an
meiner großartige investition
ich freue mich dass wir dem kommando
militär polizei und militär streife ein
nicht mehr zeitgemäßes besonders
geschütztes mehrzweckfahrzeug übergeben
können sondern dass wir damit auch zwei
deutliche signale abgeben
erstens das österreichische bundesheer
investiert wieder in zeitgemäßes gerät
und zweitens dass uns gemeinsam
der schutz unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz sein großes anliegen
ist